cette marinière si l'on se trouve dans
les décors de marina qui prend enfin qui
prend fin weborama vous vivez ça baisse
ça nous fait beaucoup de peine parce que
cela fait quatre ans que c'est notre
maison c'est ce qu'on dit tout le temps
et en même temps mais on a quand même
fait quatre saisons ce qui est
extraordinaire parce qu'aujourd'hui mois
justin tuck ses 4 1 dans un même show
aujourd'hui en télé c'est quand même
extraordinaire ça équivaut quasiment à
10 ans y aucun renvoi
comment vous voyez cette grande
transformation en ateliers
mais j'avoue honnêtement je comprends
pas toujours le tout ce que ça veut dire
le les virages comme tel mais en même
temps c'est bien évident que si je
regarde juste mon fils moi la preuve de
mon fils de 16 ans et demi monfils se
soit jamais devant télévision monfils
s'était laissé sur son portable c'est
sur son téléphone c'est les gens
consomment autrement
celles et tous points tv c'est des
émissions en rattrapage en rafales d'un
gros défi pour la télé devait prendre
ses virages là aussi le les défis sont
immenses immense parce que c'est tout un
contraste avec le début de votre
carrière dans lance et compte où il n'y
avait pas de temps poste de télévision
que ça et vous avez été une méga vedette
tout le monde parle de 100 villes dans
ses comptes ses foulées ont maintenant
avec le recul c'est on était des rock
stars partout où on allait c'était la
folie furieuse
chaque un sujet tu vas nous mettre un
trouble au fériés de mal on s'aime
s'enlève rien personne je considère
vraiment que j'ai vécu les plus belles
années de la télé ben oui parce que
c'était le 16 mm un film stade et bob
impression d'être mais c'était sûr
c'était un film
et c'est extraordinaire puis j'ai fait
des projets absolument exceptionnelle
moi j'étais très très gâtés dans ma
carrière de travailler avec des gens
formidables qui m'ont fait confiance
qu'ils m'ont donné des rôles en or
qu'est-ce que tu es tu arrivé je suis
rentré de ne pas lancer contient été mon
premier projet de l'eau ça s'est
enchaîné est arrivé oui les filles de
caleb été revus d'autre à faire avancer
espionner jeu pour qu'ils arrivent du
mal à cause de l'infamie la grenouille
et la baleine ans j'ai tourné une série
qui s'appelait l'aurait le papy
coproduction c'est là que j'ai connu
jean bodin s'effectuer était vraiment de
fil en aiguille trois mois et andré on
va faire toute une équipe
avez vous des fans qui vous suivent
depuis plusieurs endroits et voilà déjà
qui me sens en avant des noms puis j'en
sais c'est 8000 la ici je le vois tous
les jours parce qu'on est devant public
fait c'est ce que j'ai un contact direct
et après l'émission prend des photos
pont parle
la majorité des gens me disent on suit
la vie dans ces contrées que ça fait
plus vous en connaissez certains ya ici
ou ici on a eu des abonnés pendant
quatre ans l'homme est vraiment le deal
with que je salue c'est pas louise si
vous allez voir cette émission là où
cette entrevue le moment donné louise
est venu ici 75 fois en quatre ans
bonjour monsieur alphonse au cours des
prochaines semaines on va pouvoir dans
la troisième saison de deuxième chance
je vous présente
alexandre martchenko raté entre était de
nature j'espère encore que perdre
nickelés ou me repère ne soient que des
distractions aussi dans la télésérie une
autre histoire où vous incarnez une
femme qui est atteinte de d'alzheimer
une façon précoce c'est ça d'être un
report pur très facile à jouer comment
vous l'avez préparer ce rôle c'est pas
facile à jouer je le dis puis je
l'assumé totalement
c'est probablement le rôle le plus
complexe que j'ai eu à jouer
alzheimer oui alzheimer précoce c'est le
personnage d'anne aymone qui à 53 ans
mère de six enfants dont trois que
l'abandonner 30 ans plus tôt et on la
retrouve 30 ans plus tôt dans sa
deuxième vie ma tête a décidé de me
joins tour cette maladie m'obligerait à
taire à jamais ma première fille moi
tout dévoiler avant de l'avoir vraiment
oubliée alors très très beau personnage
qui a beaucoup de couches bébés des
coachs dans ce personnage mais mamie et
le comice est stone le quand j'étais
petit comme toi
q allez-vous rencontrer les personnes
atteintes dans le vent j'ai rencontré
une femme voit et c'est sûr que tout est
dans le scénario évidemment mais on est
toujours curieux de voir un peu plus
loin à l'extérieur pour se faire aussi
sa propre idée de ce qu'on a envie de
faire
et oui je rencontre une fille qui à 48
ans aujourd'hui qui est atteinte depuis
deux ans et
c'est très touchant c'est très
bouleversant de voir cette jeunesse là
et de voir le cerveau qui s'effrite qui
c'est très troublant c'est une maladie
très très troublant puis peut-être
davantage chez quelqu'un de plus jeune
parce que comme tout comme pas logique
de voir le cerveau qui qui s'envoient
qui s'endort qui est de voir quelqu'un
de jeune que toute la fougue la vis à 48
ans attendait de l'énergie marine a
reçus merci merci beaucoup merci à vous